Good morning, John.
The world is fascinating.
You can take pretty much anything in the world
and drill down far enough to find convoluted
tales of hilarity and intrigue.
We're gonna do that right now... with this.
The pound sign, the number sign, the hash
symbol, different names in different countries,
and understandably.
In America, a shifted three on a standard
keyboard is called a pound sign.
In the UK, a shifted three on a standard keyboard
is also called a pound sign, but they are
completely different characters, what the
frick?
Weirdly enough, they actually both have the
same origin: the Latin phrase for weight,
libra pondo.
It's the same reason that pound is abbreviated
lb.
Despite the fact that that is super dumb.
Now in the middle of the last millennium,
bookkeepers would scribble so fast while they
were writing down weights that lb started
to look like maybe it was a 16, they weren't
quite sure, it was unclear, so they started
to cross the top of the lb.
Their frantic scribbling intensified to the
point where it started to look like this.
And that there is the missing link between
this, and this.
However, this symbol had pretty much fallen
completely out of use until the end of the
19th century.
That's when the Teletype Corporation was inventing
binary codes for the transmission of letters.
In the UK, the symbol code for the pound sign
was 10111.
But in the US, because apparently we don't
need pound signs or even want to look at them,
they decided to make that pound sign not the
UK pound currency symbol, but the old, obsolete
pound sign.
This is the moment where the magic happened.
Because this symbol didn't actually mean very
much, it started to become a catchall symbol
for when someone needed a non-confusing symbol
for something.
This is probably how it became known as the
number sign, you put it before a number to
indicate that the number is a number.
Which is so extremely non-useful that I refuse
to accept that this thing is called a number
sign.
I know it's a number because it's a number!
Next step in the process: Bell Labs is developing
touch tone phones in the 1960s.
The engineers at Bell Labs see the potential
for phones to control machines and computers,
so they want to add two extra buttons that
aren't numbers that can be used for those
purposes.
Originally, it was a five-pointed star and
a diamond, but the engineers at the company
insisted that it be a character that was in
the newly created ASCII Code System.
And neither of those symbols were in there.
After much deliberation, they went with the
asterisk which looked a lot like the star
and the kinda unnamed symbol in question because
it wasn't really being used for anything else,
so it wasn't confusing.
So, it was included on phones, and remarkably
enough if I go to the keypad, it's still on
there!
Because it was used by Bell Labs on their
phones, it became a standard, culturally understood
symbol so much so that it was included on
the standard American keyboard.
Once again, in place of the British Pound
sign, despite the fact that there was not
really any good use for it.
Now the engineers at Bell Labs in the sixties
seemed to have recognized that there wasn't
a good name for this thing because in their
manuals that they distributed to different
people about how to use their devices, occasionally
when referring to this sign, they would have
a little footnote that would say "also sometimes
known as an octothorpe" or possibly octatherp.
This was a joke, an Easter egg, but it actually
for a couple of decades caught on in the engineering
community because engineers love jargon, and
because, I mean in my opinion at least, octothorpe
is a better word than any of the other options.
Now you might argue that with the arrival
of the social media hashtag, another use by
the way made possible by the symbols prevalence
without having a particular use.
Hash sign seems the logical way to go; that's
what it's called in most of the world, though
in America we still say pound sign even though
that's terribly confusing.
But for those of us who would rather have
our language defined by cheeky nerds of the
1960s than by the whims of social media, for
us, we'll always have octothorpe!
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
Good news everyone, after like a year of working
on this, we have launched a new DFTBA.com
merch store.
It's prettier and more functional and you
don't have to use PayPal and you can buy posters
and shirts at the same time.
We've just launched a few new designs, one
of them I've had to blur a little bit.
And one of them is a pre-order for all my
octothorpe lovers out there.
Represent.
Hashtag octothorpe!